et bah si elle aime beaucoup michel
drucker mais pourquoi est il est est ce
justifié
sur bfm tv c'est tout à fait nette
ajustée de sa présence on peut être dans
l'empathie et je stocke totalement
comprendre là la partie qu'il a fait
pour présenter hier son émission
n'envoyez pas besoin de remettre de
faire une re détruite en rendant ce que
je comprends ce qu'il dit forcément des
gens conduit dire qu'il en a fait des
caisses et sa exact c'est horrible de
dire voilà ce que drucker je pense que à
la télé un des mecs les plus honnêtes si
c'est pas lui c'est vrai quoi reconnaît
michel depuis des années claude michel
ça a été un des seuls à toujours m'avoir
aidé quoi qu'il arrive
franchement j'ai été stagiaire la
comédie i nous parler j'étais voilà à
chaque fois il a toujours voulu aider
celle drucker que tu as un amour gp
reconnu voilà il est toujours
bienveillant et bien d'autres étaient
sincères oui gilles verdez je trouve que
maxime l'a vraiment ce que vous dites
n'est absolument pas fondées parce que
c'était superbe interview autres bourdin
et lui se disait plein de choses il y
avait de l'émotion y avait aucun
exhibitionnisme c'était juste deux
personnes de qualité qui voudraient
plein d'infos que l'on puisse penser que
son émotion était fake c'est ça le point
alors non mais oui en tout cas on peut
quand même pas juger un homme qui pleure
parce qu'il est malheureux enfin bon
sens et un reste d'humanité dans un
monde qui est déjà difficile où en est
violent entre nous et y aura toile les
bouleversants prévu avant qu'il vienne à
celle des producteurs
c'est une des questions de bourdin
l'émission était très bien de très bonne
tenue
il faut vraiment être très aigrie pour
pouvoir imaginer que touquet rejouer la
comédie faudra alors vous